um what are your favorite animes oh my
god here we go
it's jesus yeah that is the question we
get asked all the time
you know what it's the hong kong bank
your favorite is a little bit 14 year
old so can i rephrase the question
what are you watching at the moment joey
at the moment yeah uh i just caught up
on attack on titan
okay the whole damn thing well i mean
what it's up to currently yes yeah um
because i feel like watching attack
watching uh no i watched through series
one i haven't watched it they're doing
yourself a different service yeah
it's a lot better it just gets better
yeah yeah it just gets better because i
started series two and there was a lot
of talking and not much happening so i
was a bit like
season two is like they're throwing a
lot of politics into the story
and and it seems boring at first no
trust me
i think i think everyone was out there
watching peppa pig and they put the
[ __ ] politics
don't get me started
no but like i think everyone was at that
point when season two started they were
like oh god
where's the action where's the high
octane action everyone came for season
one but then
after a while you quickly start to
realize oh this is very
important to the story and it just gets
you more invested in that world
it makes the world more and more
interesting as you go along
so by the time you get to season four
it's got the same action-packed
kind of roller coaster ride but then you
also the stakes are so much harder
the stakes are like way higher yeah um
right
so what season are they up to now so
it's currently it's up to four it's just
like a conversation with my dad
this is anime it's great
calm down what is the last anime that
comes out
you know you you just stop doing color
stop watching anime and read a good book
these days they watch too much anime i'm
one of now i do not want for a second
want to take away from
the seriousness of the health crisis of
cover 19. but one of the advantages of
this pandemic has there's been a lot of
time at home
yeah to do things such as catch up on
anime yes so
i've been catching up on a great school
oh
it's fantastic yeah and uh ken ganashila
i haven't seen kanye
here's the more important question do
you watch jojo
don't oh you would you would
you i would absolutely you are literally
a jojo you are you are a jojo character
why have i not been put in this element
yet
you could have been in the hong kong dub
for all
yeah i mean i think i think you'll
genuinely love it and i think with bucky
as well like if you give it a little bit
of a chance
i think i i i got a feeling the reason i
didn't get into barky was like the dvd
was broken
i got a feeling it's also on netflix
that's why now this excuse doesn't work
yeah yeah um
yeah but i'm watching us should i watch
that because no i haven't
thought this is a blast for me to say
like i just thought it was like inferior
backy
did you watch it you watched the whole
thing i watched two episodes i was like
no it's cause of the 3d i
i don't know i just was watching it i
was just like every itch was scratched
better by becky
i feel that main character whose name i
can't remember the little weenie dude
who's what from barky no no no from
kangan i should have
yeah whoever he is
i look at him and i'm like i know this
man
there are so many japanese men who are
like that you know oh really just like
black was awesome
how awesome i am you know what i'm
saying no we don't
we're not gonna lie we don't know feel
that something like that
has a certain uh essence of japaneseness
in it
and there are so many people in this
country who have been
forced into a profession or a series of
activities that they are not into
right and they just yearn to be a
different person right and then
they there's they'll be whatever they
are the otaku for
yeah pro wrestling or anime or idols
whatever it is
it's like they get to totally embrace
yeah so to that end
ken ganashita actually despite the
ridiculousness of it feels
quite real to me right okay and i think
i appreciate it now because i've lived
in japan for a long time you're really
selling hangouts
right now i feel bad for calling it you
know what you
should you should my friend i'll give it
another shot
do it give another shot right now
so you said you watched agresso have you
caught up to season three uh no not yet
see i'm getting through them you see
okay
i would be very interested to see what
your opinion of season three yes
actually yeah yeah yeah you're right
like anyway like i don't want to spoil
you but
uh let's say the parallels are apparent
yeah yeah yeah what the parallels
between that king and ashley parallels
between
season three and you yeah